what the
yo lebron i told you save the space jam
[ __ ] fade brooklyn well shucks i
will [ __ ] up an aau team i do not care i
need to talk [ __ ] too
[Music]
well i just shoot from the bench skinny
mother
two out of three next time larry legend
hey watch your back oh oh was that a
wormhole god bless america man i have so
many questions twenty thousand
get this man some cake so he doesn't
look like a hipster oh you car
what what the hell is this
hey
it's hard for a man like me to say this
but thank you i will never forget you
no it was my pleasure i'm talking to the
shoes
fella what the hell happened to delphi
play me i need to prove to future you
that i am better man get off me soft
serve elijah
look what white people from the internet
talk to me what the hell is the internet
don't y'all have guards not really
my god this guy's less of a role model
than me don't look don't look
what a crossover is that legal that's a
carry but if we have the power of time
control why are we using it for
basketball debates to gain the answers i
must beat the answer
all right bro we get it i'm a huge
influence on
kyrie scores remember take time for
yourself you're right i'm gonna skip the
next couple of games
not a game i was talking about practice
you